we have some breaking news to bring you
now and it's a pretty big story too
live to our city editor mark clyman who
joins me on the phone mark what have you
got
yes ian this concerns the philip green's
high street empire
arcadia group which i understand is now
facing collapse
within days putting as many as 15
000 jobs at risk now i'm told that
arcadia
which owns topshop burton and dorothy
perkins among other brands
is preparing to appoint administrators
from deloitte as soon as
monday of next week now if this does
happen it would effectively bring the
curtain down in on the high street
career of one of britain's most
controversial
businessmen arcadia has been in talks
for the last few weeks with a number of
lenders about
an emergency 30 million pounds loan to
keep the business
afloat but sources say that those talks
have not resulted in a deal
making arcadia's administration
inevitable now this of course comes 18
months after philips empire secured some
breathing space through a
creditor approved insolvency mechanism
called a company voluntary arrangement
which kept the business trading
but like many other high street
businesses it's seen its finances
decimated by the kobit 19 crisis and one
of the key questions
ian is going to be how many of those 15
000 jobs
can be saved i understand that if the
administration is confirmed early next
week the arcadia shops which are
currently allowed to trade under
lockdown restrictions
will remain open as will its online
operations that means it's a so-called
trading administration
but it will of course raise questions
about whether
many of those jobs have a future uh
given that some of the bidders for
arcadia's assets the likes of topshop
are likely to be online only retailers
and of course this marks in a dismal
climax mr philips career
as one of the most prominent figures to
destroy britain's
retail industry in reality it's been
something of a tortured decline
for him he saw his reputation trashed
after the one pound sale of bhs
the department store chain in 2015 to
the bankrupt dominic chappelle
with the chain collapsing a year later
and leaving sir philip
fighting a bitter battle before agreeing
to contribute
363 million pounds to its pension pot
there will be a lot of
interested pension scheme members of
arcadia waiting to see what happens
if the company does go into
administration and i should point out in
that arcadia uh did not respond to a
request for comment this morning but i
suspect we will hear confirmation of
this
uh news about arcadia going into
administration
in the coming days mark what about the
position of sir philip
himself do you think it's at all
possible if this business does go into
administration that he might try and buy
parts of it back out of administration
uh my sense in from talking to people
close to philip is that that's
unlikely at this stage i i think he's
clearly been uh bruised and battered by
the events of the last few years
and people who have been around the
arcadia situation
in recent months say that he has been
trying to find a solution that's in the
best interests
of the company's employees and other uh
stakeholders but my sense would be that
he's on
an unlikely bidder for any of the
um any of the companies brands remember
so philip
bought arcadia back in 2002 he paid
about 850 million pounds for it and then
just three years later uh the company's
ultimate owner
uh phillips wife lady tina green uh
received one of the biggest dividend
payouts in british corporate history a
1.2 billion pounds
uh dividend uh and for many years but
civil it was indeed the self-styled king
of the british high street but in the
last few years
as consumer shopping habits have changed
and
arcadia's brands have been slow to adopt
uh
digital uh retailing expertise
it has been a company that has struggled
as i say it went through a cva
restructuring
last year and the coronavirus crisis has
just accelerated
uh shopping trends towards digital and
online channels
and away from high street retailers like
arcadia
all right mark thanks for that